[Música]
Y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ya no votas votaste uno
moverse hacia la izquierda un movimiento hacia la derecha tienes
votó con esperanza por Macron, usted es
hoy decepcionado y no tienes
Ya hiciste tu elección, bueno, tú
También estamos en casa en Francia.
días felices y me dirijo a ti
hoy plenamente con esta esperanza
para construir esta Francia de la felicidad
[Aplausos]
raja
juntos podemos negar esto
encuestas parciales sesgadas y sus
comentaristas
no silbamos votamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si realmente
tienes la intencion
para bloquear en el round 12 tengo un
propuesta más interesante para ti
hacer
esta zona de la primera ronda
tiempo severo
[Música]
metro
tengo que llegar a lo mas alto
posible contra Emmanuel Macron para que
la victoria es lo más segura posible
el resultado de la segunda ronda así que
ven y diles que tienen que
participar en esta victoria y que ellos
participar activamente
[Música]
en dos semanas crearemos el
sorpresa te prometo que nos dará
Quedan 14 días 14 días es un
eternidad la mayoría de los franceses
entran en las elecciones estos dos
últimas semanas para que podamos jugar
para convencerlos
[Aplausos]
[Música]